- Mama's going to love it.
- [Hannah] Oh, look it.
Get outta there.
- This is hard.
- Nothing tastes better than food
somebody else cooked for you.
He's never made it before.
Henry!
I do appreciate his creative toppings.
- Tomatoes!
- [Hannah] It was beautiful.
I was so pampered that day. (laughs)
How's the soup, Wy?
Hi, I'm Hannah.
I'm The World's OK-est Mom
and I get a lot of comments
saying that it looks
like I'm the only person
in my house who ever cooks.
Now, that's not true, but
it did get me thinking
that maybe it's time for
you to see what it looks
like when the boys in
my house do the cooking.
So for an entire week,
I'm out of the kitchen.
I don't even know what to expect here,
so please wish me luck.
This is probably your
mother requested episode.
The thing that makes me the most nervous
about this week is I'm in
charge of cleanup duty.
I am a cook who cleans as I go.
And Matt doesn't do that.
He cooks through the whole
meal and then tackles the rest
at the end.
I have so much fun in the
kitchen with the boys.
And so my hope is that Matt
and the boys get that
amazing bonding time.
And I'm excited to see
what they come up with.
- Tonight, we have to cook mama dinner.
It's all on us.
What do you want to cook her?
- Steak?
- Yeah steak, right?
- Fancy
- That's good. She'll like steak.
And what else?
We gotta do a vegetable, right?
- Yeah. Broccoli!
- Broccoli!
- Yeah!
High fives!
- Day one started off
pretty easy for Matt.
He leaned into his strengths
and he fired up the grill.
- [Matt] Scrub it good, we gotta clean it!
- [Hannah] Sweet Matt, are you vlogging?
- [Matt] Yeah. Are you spying on me?
(Hannah laughing)
- [Hannah] That's my job.
I was a little nervous
about him letting Jackson and Wyatt help
out around the hot grill,
but all went smoothly.
- [Matt] Good job, guys!
- [Hannah] There's not much
that the boys can do to help
when it comes to grilling.
Cause a lot of it is just
flipping and monitoring.
So they did what they could.
I really thought I was going
to have an easy this week
but I was on Henry duty
for most of the time during meal prep.
No, Wyatt, Wyatt, no. Nope.
Usually that's my time
to have a little break
and I can kind of Zen
out and do some cooking.
This time I was on full Henry duty.
There's your dad.
Look at him with his flashlight grilling.
Oh, look it.
The dinner was delicious.
I was really happy that
they thought of a vegetable,
and a protein and they even
had a side of potato salad.
How much did you guys help?
- Eight percent.
- [Hannah] Okay.
The one thing that wasn't the most
conscious was the budget.
I mean, those stakes were a
little pricey, but I'm not
going to complain because
they were delicious.
Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- Very windy day, but they're
outside cooking again.
Poured myself a little glass
of wine and now I'm going to
drink it while someone else cooks for me.
I think Matt's thinking was I
started out strong on day one.
So let's just grill again on day two.
Cheese veggie dogs,
and some cut up pickles
Are we having a vegetable?
(record scratch)
- [Matt] Ummm..
Guys.
- Matt says the vegetable is the pickles.
And I know they love me
because they made these
and no one else really likes them but me.
Usually when I cook
I make foods that I know
everyone else will enjoy.
So it was nice as the
tables turned for mealtime
Look who's trolling. Rosie!
I think he likes it.
Can I have some kranch on mine?
- [Matt] You want kranch?
- Yeah!
- [Hannah] Yeah, I want kranch.
This is kranch, it's ketchup ranch.
And it is divine.
And I just like saying it.
How could you be mad when you've
got kranch in your fridge?
Oh yeah.
We were in LA, we were at my mom's house.
Day three. We packed everything in the car
and drove to LA because
at the end of the week it
would actually be Mother's Day.
So we wanted to be there
with my mom and make it
a big family gathering.
Matt and the boys decided to
make one of Matt's specialties.
He loves to make tortilla soup.
- [Matt] Put the beans
in there, boy. Yeah!
Thank you!
- Oh it smells good!
- [ Hannah] His secret that he swears
by is taking corn tortillas
and sticking them right
in the soup and letting
them dissolve to thicken it.
- [Matt] Oh, it's on a little boat.
Tortilla boat
- Soup was spectacular.
He's really, really good at it.
And it never turns out the same way twice.
He just kind of goes
and put stuff in and it turns
into something delicious.
This is so good.
Ten out of ten, Matt.
What are we thinking
about, oh Jackson finished?
- Oh yeah.
- [Hannah] Wy? What do you think?
Wyatt gets really overwhelmed
by a big looking amount of food.
He likes little bites.
So I just got this plate, but
basically you put the food
in each container and then
there's a treasure in here
and this has been amazing
for Wyatt cause he loves it.
Right?
Once I moved it into that
plate, he enjoyed it so much.
Total mom hack.
It's one of the most
brilliant things I've seen
in a very long time.
How's the soup, Wy?
I smell something what's cooking?
- [Matt] You'll find out.
- [Hannah] I'm gonna look.
- [Matt] No, no, no! Get out of there.
- I'm looking.
Oh, French fries.
Whoa!
They're dark.
Are you over cooking them?
- No
- What did you forget to do?
- Turn them.
- He didn't turn them.
This is the thing --
- [Matt] You know, I actually
like things that are more
brown.
- He does this every time.
You know, he'll make a
mistake in the kitchen
but it's I like it.
So keep going.
I think it's something he
passed along to the boys.
- I totally meant to make
her waffles kind of frozen.
Totally meant to do that.
- [Hannah] What are you doing?
- Just cutting up my french fry pizza.
- [Hannah] French fry pizza?
They decided they wanted
to make French fry pizza.
It's something that I make
with them quite a bit.
So of course they asked
Matt to try to make it.
He's never made it before.
What did you put on it?
- [Matt] Olives.
- [Hannah] This antipasto mix?
- [Matt] Yeah.
- [Hannah] Wow. And you
cooked it in a cake pan.
- [Matt] Yup.
- [Hannah] All right...
Not the most aesthetic French fry pizza
but it tasted amazing.
It's actually sticking together kind of
which is surprising to me.
Okay.
Seven point five out of ten.
Did you enjoy yours?
(Henry babbling)
- The boys were so happy to have it.
They'd wanted it for a really long time.
Are you proud of it?
- Yeah. So good.
- Day five. I decided
to make a food request.
I would like a french omelet this morning.
- What's a french omelet?
- A french omelet?
- I've never had one.
I've just seen pictures of it.
- [Matt] Are they the
little rolled up ones?
- [Hannah] So you know what it is.
- [Matt] Yeah.
We're going to have Jackson
do the cracking, I think.
And you'll do the whisking.
- Get the whisk!
- [Matt] Okay, Wyatt, you
ready to start whisking?
Right, Wyatt, good job, buddy!
- While they're making the French omelets.
I'm with Henry.
- Bah!
- Bar, you've got a bar.
He is really silly.
He's a really silly kid
and he's a lot of fun.
Who's that?
- Baba.
- Baby!
Blow a kiss to baby?
So sweet.
- [Matt] So the tricky part
will be to try to, to roll this.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, I almost had it.
- [Hannah] The sounds coming
from the kitchen when they
were doing the flip was
like someone had just
scored the winning touchdown
at the super bowl.
- Oh!
(Matt and Jackson cheering)
- [Matt] We add something to the top.
What are these?
- Uh, micro greens?
- [Matt] Micro greens?
- Yeah.
- [Matt] We're just gonna put
the little green parts on it.
Not the twigs.
- Oh my gosh.
This looks amazing!
Did I enjoy it?
A hundred percent.
It was great. It was a
really, really buttery omelet.
- [Matt] Is it good?
Oh that is good.
Thank you boys.
This is my dream fulfilled.
Henry is what's yours is mine
through and through the second they
laid those eggs in front of me.
He goes with his whole hand
and grabs my entire omelet to
try to start leading it like a burrito.
I'm in for it with this kid.
I hear some struggling happening
(Boys struggling)
in the kitchen.
So I feel like I should help.
The day six, I was not clued
into what was being prepared
but clearly the boys all had big plans.
(laughs) What are you
watching?
- God.
- Matt comes in, he's got a coconut
and a big knife and I'm thinking
what could you possibly
be making with this?
- What?
(laughs)
(Matt yells)
- [Hannah] Why coconut?
- They're struggling with the knife.
So Jackson and Wyatt had
this brilliant idea to
chuck it outside, to try to break it.
- [Matt] Oh my gosh!
- Oh my god I heard the liquid.
- They finally got the coconut open
and I still had no idea
what they were using for.
Is this like your fuel,
to make something else?
- We're going to use the meat.
Let's the squeeze some
oranges and some lemons.
- [Jackson] I'm gonna put
cilantro into the bowl.
- [Hannah] They're chopping tomatoes,
they're chopping onions.
I don't understand how that goes
along with coconut.
- Tomatoes.
- Ooh. Special delivery.
They were making vegan ceviche.
I'm so excited.
Oh my gosh.
I have never really had much ceviche
cause it always has shrimp in it!
Thank you.
Okay. Let's try it.
It's hard to believe this is coconut.
Ooh, this is good, you guys.
I felt really special.
You know, Matt thought of the recipe.
He thought of my dietary restrictions.
The boys actually enjoyed it.
I was really surprised
because it had a lot
of ingredients that Wyatt
definitely won't touch
but it's that thing
of when he helps he's way
more willing to taste it.
Thank you I appreciate this!
- You're welcome.
It was delicious.
It's Mother's day.
I have my coffee and my mask
and the boys are making
some sort of complex brunch.
They decided to make eggs benedict
because to them it's an
exciting breakfast food.
And I know Matt especially
loves eggs benedict
For a beginner cook eggs
benedict is pretty difficult.
There are many points at
which the recipe can go south.
And unfortunately for Matt
he pretty much went south at all of them.
I can't not say something.
Oh my god. Matt!
- [Matt] Oh I didn't swirl it.
(bleep) (bleep)
- Matt! Oh my God, he's
trying to poach eggs.
And all he's doing is spooning.
The yolks.
That's all the egg whites. Matt!
Can I help you?
Can I show you one?
I didn't want him to get too discouraged
with the recipe and I
didn't want to deter him
from trying new recipes in the future.
So I offered to teach him
how to poach one egg just
so he could see a clear example
and then he could take it
and go from there.
And then drop the egg in. Okay.
- [Jackson] Oh my god.
- [Jackson And Wyatt] Three! Two! One!
- [Hannah] Once he saw
the first one being made,
he knew what to do
and he did a really good job for the rest.
Arguably, the hardest part
of eggs Benedict is the hollandaise sauce.
- [Matt] Oh,
oh my goodness.
Okay! You did it.
- No shells.
- [Matt] No shells! (laughs)
- Dijon mustard.
- [Matt] No, no, no. No, nope.
Just.
- Let's just say in the kitchen,
Matt's probably not the most
clear communicator and Jackson
isn't the best listener.
So it really wasn't the best combo to
make something as complex
as hollandaise sauce.
- [Matt] This is for the holiday sauce.
Hollandaise.
- [Hannah] Holiday sauce (laughs)
- [Matt] Can you stop
talking in the background?
- Matt is stressed.
He was like muttering to himself
and making frustrated noises.
Are you doing okay?
- This is really hard.
(Hannah laughs)
- [Hannah] So happened here.
- [Matt] Yeah. It didn't
quite come out like we wanted.
- [Hannah] Are you going to blend it?
- I'm gonna try about anything.
- [Hannah] (laughs) Are you okay?
- I'm disappointed.
- [Hannah] (laughs) I'm
sure it's gonna be good.
What went wrong with
that hollandaise sauce
is he used a fork to mix the eggs
and didn't fully mix them or aerate them.
So there were chunks
of egg white in there.
So he threw it in the blender
and blended it to try to get
it a little more whipped.
- Didn't go as smoothly as I wanted.
It was kind of a debacle,
Hannah had to save me twice.
Hey, you know what?
We tried a really tricky
dish and she's happy.
So that's all I counts.
- [Hannah] This looks amazing.
I like my poached eggs on the firm side.
So let's see how they did.
Ooh! (gasps)
The egg was poached so perfectly.
It was delicious.
Oh wow.
Thank you guys.
Best mother's day brunch ever.
And because it was mother's day,
Matt and the boys agreed to do the dishes
and I got that day off.
By the end of the week I was so grateful
for all of the beautiful food.
I was really proud of them
for all of the effort they put
into it.
And I was also really ready
to start cooking again.
You may see me do the majority
of the cooking and that's
because that's, what's fun for me.
That's what I love to do.
But it was really fun to see
Matt take on all the cooking
for a week.
So that's all for now.
I'm Hannah.
And please let me know on Instagram, who
does the cooking in your house and please
let Matt know what a good job
he did on all of his recipes.
Now, if you'll excuse us
I have some cooking to do and
he has some cleaning to do.
Till next time.
- Bye guys.
(cheerful ukulele)